The Joe Rogan Experience elon's a
[ __ ] wizard man yeah I'm really
interested to see what he does with
Twitter
because he bought nine percent oh that's
right I read an article today though I
didn't read the article excuse me I read
a headline today that said that uh he
might have done something illegal by
buying that stock oh really
yeah but like but what is that what
could he have done
I don't understand that what um what was
it wasn't interested enough to read what
was his motivation for disclosure of the
purchase
the disclosure of the purchase that he
disclosed it that's what it's the timing
of the disclosure it says yeah
I think you know is that when you make a
giant purchase like that not disclosing
it in a certain amount of time can
affect things
like the fact like how other people buy
it sure um sell it or do whatever they
right affect the stock price
yeah I'm interested to see because uh I
hear they're gonna put an edit button
now because that was one of the things
that he suggested and he made a poll do
you think Twitter should have an edit
button and he said yes
who at its what you whether you can edit
it like you write something and you
write 1945 but you met 1965 like [ __ ]
you have to delete the tweet and start
all over again and he wants the he was
like made a poll should Twitter have an
edit button and the vast majority of
people said yes so let's see if they
Implement that yeah
okay it's a 50 year old law that
requires an investors notify the
Securities and Exchange Commission when
they surpass a five percent stake in a
company musk reach that Benchmark on
March 14th according to the filings but
he made his public disclosure only
Monday
yeah in between he continued to buy
stock at the price of around 39 per
share bringing his total stake to 9.2
percent after his to close disclosure
Twitter share price Rose roughly 30
percent and is now above 50 dollars per
share oh [ __ ] yeah yeah so basically if
he had disclosed earlier that he was
buying it the price would have risen
faster yes got it maybe that would have
been bad for him because he wouldn't be
able to get it at the same rate yeah
exactly if he
if he's actually listened to so I don't
know like how much power a person who's
worth nine percent has over a company
well he's the biggest uh owner right the
biggest stakeholder shareholder but if
he did they have to listen to him though
you know what I'm saying like do they
have to listen to him in terms of like
whether they want to ban people whether
they want to have an edit button whether
or not they want to apply the principles
of the First Amendment to something like
Twitter right well maybe it's the it's
the fear that if he were to dump all the
stock it would hurt the price so they
want to keep him happy I was having a
conversation with a couple friends
yesterday about this and one of them is
dealing with comments on another social
media platform and what they were saying
was that
you know what Twitter does by Banning
people and censoring people is
definitely bad but there are some
[ __ ] horrible people that were banned
by Twitter that are now ruining these
other social media apps and they were
explaining to me like what's happening
and how these people comment on these
other apps about how toxic they are and
about they have like a whole group of
people that have also been banned that
find these new social media apps and
that's that's where they congregate and
hang out and that's their Community now
and it's just it's just Chernobyl it's
just toxic what are the other apps well
there's a shitload of them I don't want
to name the one they're like this person
was talking to me about okay
specifically because I don't want to
[ __ ] up because I think I believe in
these other apps I believe in
all these other alternative platforms
and I think that there's Great Value in
having competitors whether it's to
Twitter or to YouTube or to any of these
Facebook any of these giant huge
companies that have a massive pipeline
to the consciousness of the world
because the what the ability to
distribute information on Twitter or on
Facebook or like that is unprecedented
there's never been a thing like that
where privately owned company has the
ability to get ideas out there that can
change the way elections are on to
change the way so many things are
thought of in this country I think we
need Alternatives and I think we need
Alternatives that adhere to free speech
but the problem is when they've got
these shitty people that they've kicked
off of these other platforms like
Twitter because Twitter is pretty
ruthless about it then they go to these
other places and they run amok and then
like hey Free Speech you need Free
Speech but then there's they're
organizing harass assessment campaigns
and [ __ ] with people and targeting
them all day long and constantly
commenting on them and like
I don't know if that's good either yeah
you know that would make me not want to
go there if I that was I was this person
so like but I don't like what Twitter
did like I don't think Twitter should
have banned Trump I don't think I think
that was a terrible idea it's a terrible
precedent to set that you you can decide
that you don't like a guy who's a
[ __ ] sitting president of the United
States at the time and kick him off your
platform because you don't like the
things he's saying hmm